hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar producing recombinant proteins
with a bacular virus expression Vector
system bevs I am Julie abing of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by cyanobiological to
learn more visit synobiological.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation I'd like to now welcome our
speaker Zoo xiaozing r d project manager
cyanobiological Inc sujao you may now
begin your presentation
hello everyone nice to see you all this
is a raptor from xenobiological
my name is and I'm an r d manager here
at Sino
my work mainly focuses on the design and
troubleshooting of recumbent protein
expression methods
today I would like to talk about the
bacular virus expression Vector system
or Buffs in shot
in this talk we will discuss the history
of Bachelor virus expression its
applications and the strategies that we
employed under Rick paths
okay now let's begin today's weather the
main content and the sequence of this
talk are shown here let's take a closer
look at the bags
there are two key elements in the Box
specular virus and inset cells
I will talk in detail about them in the
following slides
firstly let's take a closer look at
background writers
Vector virus is a large family of
viruses with large double-stranded
circular DNA genomes
the main hosts of these viruses are
insects the most famous specular virus
is ACM and PV
this virus is harmless to human making
it a suitable Vector for recombinant
expression
in fact most expression vectors we use
in the best are engineered based on the
ACM and PV genome
once the host is depicted
the physiological process of the virus
is divided into four phases
this figure shows the genes
the third transcribed in different
phases
let's review the replication cycle of
the bachelor virus
infection occurs when a larval consumes
inclusion bodies which travel to the
midgard
the alkaline environment of the meat gut
causes the occlusion bodies to develop
releasing the occlusion derived viruses
or odinis
only this excess the cloneard cells
nuclear capsides is released migrated to
the nuclear to deliver the viral genome
and the Cascade of gene expression
events starts
but it virus production begin between 6
and 24 hours
causing a systemic infection of the host
during the very late phase nuclear
capsides are retained in the nucleus and
the odv sir embedded within a
crystalline Matrix of polyhedron to form
occlusion bodies
which will be released after cellulitis
the occlusion bodies persist stable in
the environment waiting for the next
susceptible host
our understanding of baccular virus is
derived from a long history of research
the topic was first reviewed in 1953
in 1971 ACM and PV was discovered
virus particles were isolated in 1973.
subsequently more information such as
the virus structure life cycle genome
map and the physiology was obtained
which was helpful for the development
and modification of recombinant specular
virus factors
in the history of vector development
linear radiation of the ACM and PV
genome was regarded as a milestone
they established Vector would then use
to express the competent proteins
human beta interferon was the first
protein produced successfully by its
baths
since then many researchers have
contributed towards improving the
performance of this system
a major Improvement was the generation
of an exam and PV Pack Meat
the back meat can be applied and
modified in E coli
which makes it much easier to use
with more research
various expression systems were
established such as flashback bigback
and smart back
all of them are commercial systems you
can fight the fight them online
Buffs has become a universal platform to
express recombinant proteins
which fight using drug Discovery
structural analysis of vaccine
development and other applications
now let's have a look at the host
in Virtual instant cell culture has a
long history
in 1915 German scientists cultured spur
merchants
the sales could be maintained for
several days in Rachel but no cell
division was observed
a major breakthrough came in 1959 then
scientists successfully established the
first cell line derived from ovarian
tissue
it had been cultured for more than 30
Generations
in 1962 scientists successfully
established another cell line again
dropped from ovarian tissue
which had been continuously passaged for
44 Generations
with the development of inset cell
cultural technology
scientists established the sf-21 cell
line from ovarian tissue in 1970.
confirmed this doubling time and
reported that it was sensitive to a cm
and PV
in 1983 the sf9 cell line was derived
from sf-21 and subsequently applied for
recombinant expression
in 1986 the
tn5b101 was established from embryo
tissue
and the tn5b1 for sale line was cloned
from tn5b1 in 1994.
English version applied for a patent on
this cell line and registered it under
the trademark name high five
high five cells displaying a high
expression level and are widely used for
recombinant protein expression
more recently in 2010 the ao38 cell line
was established from embryonic tissue
these cells are highly sensitive to ACM
and PV and shown a higher protein
expression level than s7i and high five
cells which is the suggestive of their
potential
however no commercial AO 38 cell line
has been developed yet
currently three commercial inside cell
lines are widely used
sf21 sf9 and hi-fi
sf9 is suitable for producing macular
virus expression proteins and Performing
the black assay
both sf-21 and high five can be used to
expression intracellular and secreted
proteins
according to our experience recumbent
protein yield is usually hiring high
five learning sf9 so high five cells are
mainly used for protein production here
at stenobiological
we have briefly recovered the two major
components of the bags now let me show
you how the system works
before we do that I think it's necessary
to quickly review the common hosts used
for recombinant protein expression
currently there are four major
expression hosts bacteria yeast
mammalian cells and of course insect
cells each system is unique and can be
used to become recombine expressions
the host cells used by the bacterial
expression system are simple organism
usually E coli the advantages of the
system include cost Effectiveness and
child but the limitations of bacterial
render the system on suitable for
proteins that require post to
translational modifications
is to have the capacity for
post-translational modifications but
their glycosylation type is high metals
momentum cells also have the capacity
for post-translational modifications but
the system is costly and not suitable
for producing nutracellular proteins
such as structural proteins enzymes and
transcription factors
the baths by contrast is more widely
used for expression both intracellular
and the secretary proteins
the target protein will be trans opposed
to translationally modified and high
destination cell culture can be achieved
background virus expression vectors can
accommodate large fragments of foreign
genes
accommodating large molecular weight
proteins and complexes
compared with mammalian cells inside
cells are either too trans fat and
therefore either to scale up
having introduced the components and the
advantages of the system let's look at
the application of the paths
it has been successfully applied to
express various proteins and provides
sufficient materials for developing
vaccine in the forming a virus-like
particles or their piece for example
celery said a vaccine developed by jsk
using the baths to form a immunogenic
therapy with no effectivity
is the first commercial human vaccine
produced using the bath
this system can also provide raw
materials to develop diagnostic regions
for example TPO protein a key antigen to
detect autoimmune thyroid diseases
Johnson told successfully expressed
human TPO using the Buffs the recumbent
recombinant protein had high arithmetic
activity and reactive towards its
corresponding substrate
it was developed into a detection kit
and has now become a standard method for
the clinical detection
beths also provides sufficient amounts
of soluble proteins with
post-translational modification for
structural biology
unlike proteins expressed in mammalia
cells the post-translational
modification in this system don't
significantly affect the structural
analysis especially for x-ray
crystallography
the recombinant protein is can be folded
better in this system while retained its
enzyme activity
in addition the Buffs can be used to
develop biological drugs and
biomaterials
recombinant expression in the Buffs
involves Vector construction host
transfection or transformation protein
purification and other steps different
proteins required different design and
production strategies
and we will we will talk more about that
later
recombinant expression has significant
significant advantages over extraction
from natural sources
including unrestricted protein abundance
really free from animal derived
components high yield and minimum batch
to batch variations
hence many researchers expand efforts to
optimize the expression system for
better recombinant expression
foreign
used in xenobiological is based on the
back to back system a flowchart of this
process is present and presented here
briefly a genius insert into a primary
Vector which is the subsequently cloned
into a secretary Vector known as acne
back meat is transfactured into inset
cells to obtain Generation 1 baccular
virus named P1
the P1 virus is Amplified in inside
cells to achieve a suitable title which
is then used to infect insect cells for
protein expression
this back-to-back system has been
adapted to express various proteins
include security
intracellular or memory bound
one drawback of the system is a long
duration
mainly because the process is different
from other systems
there are several key factors in the
whole process
the first is the back need it's so large
that it's prone to accidental breakage
you should be careful
the second factor is the selection of
host cells in some cases different cells
have different effects on the expression
of the same protein
chromatography method depends on the
construct design and protein
characteristics
please ensure that it's appropriate for
the Target protein
now let's look at the types of proteins
that are suitable for expression using
the bats we know that specular virus
have a biophysic replication cycle
bodied virus and occlusion derived virus
hence the best can be used to
recombinantly express both the secreted
and intracellular protein
for example our product io9 is the
secreted product of the best
the extra extracellular domain of
transmembral proteins such as ha and any
of the influential viruses can also be
expressed using this system
likewise the expression of intracellular
protein is especially kinases will
succeed more likely if the best is used
it also provides a good alternative to
alternative for the recombinant
expression of transcription factors
which is usually challenging in other
systems
researchers use the best for realp
assembly Lord proteins or complexes
because of the high cultural Destiny
simple transfection method and the Hindi
of scale up this expression platform can
provide more materials for the
purification of transmembral proteins
now let's look at some of the
applications of the Buffs in recombinant
expression
to obtain fully functional recombinant
proteins a systemic design is required
for each step
from construct design to protein
purification
the first thing you need to study is the
target protein information such as the
subserver location molecular weight pi
and instability index is needed for
construct design
based on this we can decide whether both
see the best choice for the for the
recombinant expression and get a fair
idea about the difficulty involved
once the construct is determined perform
a pilot study to understand if the
strategy is workable if the result shows
that the strategy can work well
large-scale production can be
implemented as needed
now we will describe four case studies
to demonstrate key features of
recombinant protein expression using the
Box
look at the left side of the slide
here we try to express the extracellular
region of a transmembral protein as a
secreted type
we tried the four last first
as you can see in this image
no target band was observed indicating
failure of the expression
a hydrophobicity analysis of the target
sequence revealed that there are strong
hydrophobic region in the intern
we removed it from our construct and
tried again
as shown in this SDS page a truncated
protein was successfully expressed as a
pure change above 95 percent
what we learned from this case was that
hydrophobicity or other structural
features such as high disorder maybe
judgmental to recombination expression
if the regions are not directly involved
in protein function
they can be removed during construction
in such cells are often used to produce
large molecular weight proteins such as
avsn
it has five functional regions with a
molecular weight of
273 code Dalton the four less protein
was expressed
it's low yield and less than 0.5
milligram per milliliter and a beauty of
only 70 percent
an alternative approaches to express a
domain of interest rather than the four
less protein in this case however the
truncated protein was not feasible
because of the loyalt and high
degradation
finally by splicing the sequences
encoding our interest rate region
combine them with a Linker we
successfully obtained a high yield and
high Purity protein
the lesson we learned from this case was
that truncation is sometimes not a good
solution and may even make things worse
if expression of the Fallout and the
truncated version are both not feasible
splicing may be a good option
some proteins require certain oligomeric
formations to be functional
for example the human fap exists as a
homodimer
caution should be exercised during
purification because we have to ensure
protein activity we must track the
protein fractions with the crack to
oligomeric status
in this case study a histaged protein
was expressed using the baths
contained a mixture of each monomer and
the timer because the protein is active
as a diamond a second gel filtration
purification step was required to enrich
the timer
the turmeric confirmation of the final
product was confirmed by hplc the
protein exhibited reproducible asthmatic
activity across two different batches
extraction of transmembral proteins is
difficult different membrane proteins
have different detergent preference
in this example a single path
transmembral protein was expressed using
the best the target protein was poorly
extracted using detergent Formula 1 and
no purified protein was obtained
optimizing the detergent formula
enhanced protein extraction
finally Dem was used in standard of
detergent Formula 2 to stabilize the
final product
sometimes optimizing a single connection
doesn't work we must optimize the
overall strategy like in this case
the target protein was a transcription
Factor sequence analysis revealed
several risk points including High
existing content High disorder and poor
stability
we filled a GST tag to the intern to
facilitate protein expression the result
of the pilot study showed that the
protein was soluble but Affinity
chromatography has no effect
worst of all significant degradation
degradation could be observed
we've used the GRT tag to the center now
the results of the pilot study showed
Improvement in expression the phonetic
chromatography was good and the Illusion
2 contained the intact protein with
limited degradation
then we try to increase the cultural
volume protein degradation was observed
again
indicating that a small a small cultural
volume is necessary to keep the protein
stable
lastly
the stable stability test shown that
high concentration of thought was
necessary as well
that's all that I wanted to see about
the best now I would like to take a few
minutes to quickly introduce
xenobiological
say no biological is headquartered in
Beijing economic technological
Development Area and we have established
the subsidiary subsidiaries in the
United States Europe Japan as well as
Thai Joe and sudo in China
and branches in Shanghai and Guangzhou
in addition the company has dozens of
authorized Distributors around the world
to provide customers with more
convenient and efficient service service
say no biological is committed to
providing high quality recombinant
protein and antibody regions
and being a One-Stop One-Stop Technical
Services shop for life science
researchers around the world
cro technology Services mainly include
the production of recombinant proteins
and the recombinant antibodies antibody
development and biology and so on
in addition we provide an integrated
service package to assist
pharmaceutical companies and
biotechnology institutions with
pre-clinical Stage development
particularly monoclonal antibody drug
screening
product sale include recombinant
proteins antibodies genes elasticates
cultural medium and transfection regions
more than 50
000 products are available online our
products are widely used in molecular
biology cell biology Immunology stem
cell research and other branches of the
life sciences
our customers help from more than 90
countries and regions around the world
and our products have been cited in many
top journals our company is fully
qualified
that's all for today's presentation
thank you for your kind attention and I
would be happy to take any questions
thank you zuchao for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is how to ensure
purity of the recombinant macular virus
plasma you extract
okay a good question regular extraction
method will do just fine but pay
attention to the details of the
operation especially the process of
protein removal the Purity is commonly
determined by the OD 268 to 280.
the result will tell you whether there
is a RNA or protein contaminations is in
the plasmate
question two is does mli have a
significant effect on protein expression
the answer is yes
some proteins are sensitive to Moi and
differences in yield levels can be
distinctly observed when Moi gradients
are made therefore it's necessary to try
a gradient of the Moi to ensure that we
can choose a more appropriate expression
condition
okay
um and question three is how can
recombinant protein production be
increased
hmm good question there are three common
approaches it's possible to modify the
construction as in the case we have just
imagined such that changing the location
of the GST allows for better expression
you can also track it if there are some
detrimental regions as we've shown in
the slide
if your protein is secreted you can
alter the signal peptide
in addition to this
aforementioned approaches other
approaches were are worth trying to
you can do what you can and try our best
question four is do you have a good
solution to the phenomenon of cell
clumping
okay
um I didn't notice a relationship
between the fraction of cell clamping
and the level of protein expression uh
if the expression level is not affected
Let It Be
oh we've still convenience already
interviewing with recombination
expression uh anti-clamping supplements
can be tried
question five is I wanted to make a
fusion expression of different segments
is there anything to be concerned about
okay if the fragments are from the same
protein the relative positions of the
fragments should follow the original
order if the fragments are from
different proteins attention needs to be
painted to the expose of the terminals
linkers between different segments needs
to be considered us as to less and types
question number six is what is the
maximum cultural volume you can achieve
and how many viruses would you add
uh the maximum volume is
100 and 500 liter
the volume of viruses ended depends on
the virus title I can't give you the
certain
um
I can give you a certain number and tell
you how later or which liter or how much
you can add in the volume
question seven is I would like to move
the label from terminal n to Terminal C
does this have a significant effect on
protein expression
uh yes the impact could be significant
as described in the case of our weather
we've used GST tag to the n-term nodes
and Affinity orthographic has no effect
and the significant
aggregation was observed we change the
location of the GST and we purify the
protein to high purity
that is widely recommend a pilot study
this is avoidable way to check your
strategies divine
perfect and it looks like we have time
for one more question question number
eight is
designobiological accept package bacular
viruses for protein expression
uh for some uh for some routine protein
expression products uh we can also
directly use client-made baccular virus
and for protein expression also in this
since instance we will con communicate
with the client about the purification
strategy and the final delivery format
this down the actual characteristics of
the protein
well thank you again for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor cyanobiological for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand lab Roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye